[Música]
olá meu nome é ana carolina
tenho dez anos na verdade a partir de
hoje 11
e hoje eu vim falar sobre o que as
pessoas podem fazer e depois se
aposentar depois se aposentar
você gosta de ficar 20 anos ou mais no
sofá assistindo tv
nessa apresentação eu não vou falar as
palavras idoso velho e aposentado velho
porque não há palavra muito respeitosa
aposentado porque quer dizer alguém que
fique em seu aposento
então essa pessoa teria que ficar só no
seu quarto idoso porque eu tenho uma
sugestão melhor a palavra senhor as
pessoas com mais 60 anos reação 15% da
população brasileira e deve chegar a 28
por cento em 2060 a expectativa de vida
no brasil subiu de 55 anos em 1960 para
75 anos em 2015 e pode chegar a 81 anos
e 2060
neste gráfico podemos ver que a
população do senhor está crescendo ea
dos jovens está diminuindo o que
acontece com todas essas pessoas hoje
muitas não são valorizadas são
incentivados a ficar em casa não
conseguem trabalho e sua renda diminui
os problemas de ver muitas pessoas
inativas é que muitos ficam pobres
depressivos carentes sozinhos e com
baixa qualidade de vida
a sociedade não está preparada para
sustentá los
mas nós podemos ajudar dando emprego
para as pessoas e arrumando coisas que
elas gostem de fazer não só vai
carregando existe vários movimentos que
ajudam as pessoas a encontrarem talentos
que solas golpe só elas podem
desenvolver um exemplo de um caso de
sucesso de um movimento que aconteceu
vou dar a ver o nike e da marta do
everton
com 52 anos e não com 59 anos de marca
com 62 anos se conheceram e viram que
tinham tido uma ótima carreira e não
queriam parece trabalhar então criaram o
site de moradia compartilhada
esse site serve pra você procurar com é
procurar alguém que você tem gente fique
para dividir a casa com essa pessoa que
você não tinha direção sozinho
como você pode ajudar a resolver isso
eu por exemplo sei que minha avó que é
psicóloga tem 62 anos na criação de uma
clínica para crianças com síndrome de
down
para terminar essa palestra eu gostaria
de fazer algumas perguntas
se você tem uma empresa que tipo de
trabalho poderia oferecer a esse tipo de
pessoas como você está se preparando
para continuar trabalhando depois dos 60
anos
como nós podemos ajudar o senhor já
melhorar sua qualidade de vida
obrigada pela atenção
[Aplausos]